There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
We have yet another
color-changing product to review.
This is the Kylie Cosmetics
transformative liquid lip tint
that was a part of her
collab with the Wizard of Oz.
It goes from emerald green to pink.
The smell is interesting.
It kind of smells like an apple-y shampoo.
The formula is pretty thin.
I do like this giant doe-foot applicator.
The color is actually a little more unique
than other color-changing
lip products I've tried.
The pink was a bit deeper and I think
more flattering on my skin tone.
I would wear this again because
the stain it leaves behind is pretty,
but I do wish the formula was thicker.
These are the Fleeky Friday Cosmetics
Crystal Crease eyeliners.
These are handmade
reusable crystal eyeliners
that you apply with lash glue.
It was a little hard for me
to get them in a comfortable spot,
because I have hooded lids.
You can cut these to fit
your eye shape better,
so I'm going to do that next time,
but I think these are so fun.
They look like you just did so much work
applying each individual rhinestone.
Cirque Colors is one of my
favorite nail-polish brands,
and they just dropped
their holiday collection.
I love that they have a spin
on the classic red and green,
this mix of pearly shades,
and then this more unique duochrome.
Sashay reminds me of red
bows and Christmas ornaments.
To me it leans more pink than red,
but it's still beautiful.
Verdigris Jelly is a jelly polish.
It is more sheer because it's a jelly,
so I did three layers,
and it looked so shiny.
My favorite shade in the collection
is definitely Tahitian Pearl,
which is this dark duochrome
that shifts from pink to green,
and it has this holographic glitter in it.
I did three coats for this one too
because it showed the color shift better,
and I think it made the glitter pop more.
This is a really unique color,
and I can see myself wearing it a lot.
The last three shades are all
a pearlescent, sheer white
with different-colored shimmers.
Serenity has a green shimmer,
Soleil has a pinky-red shimmer,
and Siren has a purple shimmer.
These are all really pretty,
but you definitely don't need all of them,
because they're so similar.
This entire collection
applied really smoothly,
and even though some shades
had to be layered up,
I was happy with how they all turned out.
This is the Half Magic
Magic Flik liquid eyeliner.
It has this really interesting
tip that's paddle-shaped
so you can draw fine lines with the edge
and then fill in with the wide side.
I suck at eyeliner, but this shape
actually really helped
me draw the wing easily.
I will say that I think
the actual eyeliner formula
is not the best.
The black isn't super
pigmented like I would prefer,
but I really liked this tip shape.
This is the KVD Dazzle
Long-Wear Eyeshadow Stick.
It's supposed to be a
one-and-done-type product,
so you don't need primer.
You just swipe it on and blend.
I was really surprised at
how soft this formula is.
It's actually a little too soft,
like, you have to be gentle with it,
but it really does glide on easily.
This is packed with glitter and shimmer,
and it just looks so pretty on the eyes.
It's like a way to do glitter
without any of the mess. I'm a fan.
I tried a couple products from
the K-beauty brand Romand.
This glitter palette has been raved about,
so I was really excited to play with it.
The shades are meant to be on the softer,
more translucent side,
so you can layer them over eye shadow.
I just applied some of
my blush on the eyes
and then applied a few
of the shades on top.
There are shimmer formulas,
fine glitters, and more chunky glitters.
Overall, I would say the
formulas are on the dry side,
but they were actually
pretty easy to work with.
I had no problem swiping
or patting them on,
and I had little to no glitter fallout.
I also tried the Glasting Water Tint.
The color and gloss are separate layers,
so you get that long-lasting
tint with a glossy finish.
These feel so hydrating and
comfortable on the lips.
They're really lightweight,
and they definitely do leave a stain.
Look at my hand after I
wiped those swatches off.